Звільнити Юрія Луценка з посади Генерального прокурора
такі заклики від громадських активістів
лунають дедалі частіше
Зокрема, через конфлікт між ГПУ
та  Національним антикорупційним бюро.
Окрім того, Луценку закидають
невиконання обіцянок, які той давав
під час призначення на посаду.
Ось головні з них.
Я йду в Генпрокуратуру,
щоб завдяки прийнятому вами новому закону
завести нових людей з юридичною освітою
які ніколи там не працювали.
Втім, на думку експертів, системного оновлення
кадрів прокуратури не відбулося.
Хоча депутати ухвалили закон,
який дозволяв призначати в органи прокуратури
осіб з юридичною освітою,
але без стажу роботи у відомстві.
Це мало привести нових людей з-поза системи.
Однак за минулий рік відбувся конкурс
на понад 600 вакантних посад
лише в місцевих прокуратурах.
Це лише п’ять відсотків від загальної кількості прокурорів.
Аналогічні конкурси в прокуратурах вищого рівня
Луценко проводити не захотів.
Попри чітки заклики до цього Консультативної місії ЄС.
Ніколи на це б не пішов,
якби зміг знайти людину,
в яку повірив би президент,
парламент і суспільство,
що він може зламати нинішню неефективну,
а часто злочинну систему,
і має більше бажання це зробити, ніж я.
Зламати систему Луценку не вдалося.
Одіозні заступники попереднього генпрокурора
Віктора Шокіна залишились.
Серед них - Юрій Столярчук та Юрій Севрук.
Останній перейшов працювати в Академію прокуратури.
Не сталося і обіцяного очищення прокуратури.
Затверджений Луценком порядок перевірки доброчесності
передбачав подачу прокурором декларації
з відповідями на питання на кшталт
"Чи вчиняли ви корупційні діяння?"
"Чи давали ви колись незаконні вказівки?"
Експерти вважають, що такі методи
зовсім не ефективні і не є справжньою перевіркою.
На їхню думку, Луценко вирішив не йти на конфлікт з системою.
Я сподіваюсь активізувати справи
проти високопосадових осіб,
які, на жаль, останнім часом
не радують нас своєю появою в судах.
За підрахунками Центру політико-правових реформ,
торік за корупційні діяння
позбавлено волі у 3,5 рази менше осіб,
ніж 2013 року, за часів Януковича.
А останній скандал навколо "зливу" Генпрокурором
агентів НАБУ викликав шквал критики
з боку європейських і американських партнерів.
Там заявили, що ГПУ підриває віру людей
у можливість ефективної протидії корупції.
Я йду туди, щоб генпрокуратура
стала інструментом суспільства
задля справедливості і нормального життя
Прозорим інструментом суспільства Генпрокуратура не стала
підсумовують експерти.
Зокрема, закон про прокуратуру вимагає
опублікування всіх наказів генпрокурора України.
Про призначення на посади,
звільнення, вказівки підлеглим прокурорам,
розписи видатків тощо.
Втім, у Генпрокуратурі не хочуть відкривати
для суспільства результати своєї роботи
і не допускають контролю громадян за законністю її наказів.